now in the clip that you just saw the VP
referenced the Diamond Princess cruise
ship which is where my next guest
contracted the corona virus joining me
now is Carl Goldman he was a passenger
on that ship and is now under quarantine
at the University of Nebraska Medical
Center Carl how are you feeling my dear
my goodness sorry about what you've been
through how do you feel thanks thanks
Laura it's been a bit of an ordeal but I
feel fine
this virus for me was pretty light
without equal to a very very mild cold
and today I'm feeling fine unfortunately
I'm still testing positive and so I'm
gonna be stuck here for a while longer I
have a question how many times do you
have to test negative in order to be
released from quarantine
we have testing done three days in a row
and they tested with a swab that goes
deep up into each nostril and one down
the throat so they have to come up posit
have to come up negative in all three of
those three days in a row
they've gotten real high-tech out here
this is actually Omaha is one of the top
centers in the country set up by the CDC
during the anthrax scare so everything's
high-tech I was in the bio containment
area for about 10 days when I first got
here which is like a scene out of the
Andromeda Strain
and now I moved and where I am right now
is in a much lower tech area quarantine
what's funny is that again my results
everything's high-tech but here's my
results coming on a post-it note Oh my
post-it note but when you compare you
compare the disease and you were in
pretty good health when you when you
contracted it correct right I compare it
to a mild cold I I would have been a
poor if I wasn't contagious I would be
at work the next day after you know a 24
hour stretch I had the same symptoms
most people seem to be getting a feeling
fine and then then the normal
temperature zooms up in my case I was
already on the plane back to America
slept for a couple hours and woke up
with
and three plus fever mmm they put me in
a quarantine area there ended up landing
at Travis Air Force Air Force Base thing
I'm not playing and they brought me
along with my wife through Omaha the
truth is my god I'm sorry I just I have
to ask this is it true that your family
is receiving death threats is that true
yeah it's really sad so we're getting
death threats my wife who finally got
released here two days ago
returned to run our radio station we're
on the local radio station in Santa
Clarita California yes we've been
getting death threats we've been getting
hate mail one of our traveling
companions is in a hospital in Salt Lake
City he's getting death threats
authorities have had to come in it's
it's like we've got a plague or what
lepers out there it's really oh my god
it's unconscionable I mean it is
absolutely outrageous and you're
complying with what you have to do and
you're isolating and you're waiting
patiently obviously that's what you're
supposed to do and you get repaid for
that by getting death threats thanks
that's that's really it's unbelievable
well we hope you get out soon Karl and
we just pray for the rest of you know
our country and the people around the
world that you know health professionals
are doing the right thing and that our
government is has a strong response and
you know so far we you know it could
have been a lot worse but you know we'll
see where it goes Karl we'll be tracking
you thank you very much my friend get
better